[Musique]
le grand tintamarre symbole de la
présence et de la vitalité acadienne
deux cent soixante trois ans après la
déportation à karak est ils sont des
milliers à défiler au son des casseroles
des cuillères c'est des trompettes
la magie est bien présent cette année on
voulait vraiment pas avec les enfants
myla fait avoir c'est quoi comme un vrai
festival
les cloches de l'église sonne c'est le
camp des cantons qui en est fier d'être
acadien le tintamarre est important
parce que les gens les acadiens veulent
montrer qu'ils sont bien vivants le full
tricolore et doit les célèbres ses
couleurs et ses symboles qui tapissent
rusé maison c'est la fierté d'être
acadien le kazoo faut montrer aux
couleurs que c'est bleu blanc rouge avec
l'étoile tanière jamais allée
l'épauleront représente la vierge marie
les toits de la mer tout en acadie cette
fierté se manifestent bruyamment
à bouctouche au pays de la sagouine
[Musique]
ici à moncton où les jeunes chanteurs
d'acadie ont entonné leur hymne national
l'avé maris stella chez les acadiens de
la baie sainte-marie en nouvelle écosse
c'était le traditionnel tintamarre des
voitures pendant que le drapeau acadien
était hissé à halifax
la fête s'est étendue jusque dans les
plus petites communautés acadiennes
comme aux îles de la madeleine ainsi
qu'à l'île du prince édouard ceci pour
donner un exemple à tous les six ans et
s'il y en a beaucoup mais l'acadie
résonne jusqu'en normandie dans le nord
de la france
le retour au nouveau brunswick les
organismes acadiens en ont profité pour
exprimer leur demande au premier
ministre
à quelques semaines des élections brian
gallant s'est engagé à défendre
personnellement le dossier des langues
officielles
je pense qu'au moins inattendu les
célébrations se poursuivra en musique
toute la soirée avec des formations
venues d'aussi loin que la louisiane où
là aussi la quête 10 et ce par entendre
[Applaudissements]
ici nicolas peltier radio-canada moncton